nouvelle nuit d'angoisse pour les
Ukrainiens les Russes ont frappé de
nouveau des frappes massives d'après les
autorités qui mettent en garde contre
des mois difficiles à venir volody Meyer
delanski va donc faire passer le message
au Congrès américain il est arrivé à
Washington Mathieu Baba vous êtes sur
place bonjour il avait déjà rencontré
les élus américains en décembre 2022
depuis qu'est-ce qui a changé
alors oui effectivement c'est la
deuxième fois que le président ukrainien
se présente devant la représentation
nationale américaine en moins d'un an
vous avez raison et on se souvient du
caractère exceptionnel d'ailleurs qui
avait revêtu sa première visite c'était
en décembre 2022 le chef d'État avait
alors été accueilli en héros
littéralement par l'ensemble des
parlementaires jusqu'à entendre qualifié
sa visite d'historique et c'est vrai que
depuis Winston Churchill un chef d'État
au combat n'avait pas été célébré comme
cela jusqu'à sceller une forme de pacte
transpartisan au cœur même de la
diversité politique américaine essaie de
cela dont il va s'agir aujourd'hui mais
pour répondre directement à votre
question bien des choses ont changé au
cours de l'année écoulée d'abord et
c'est ce qu'a souhaiter rappeler
volodime ski en priorité le prix humain
payé par l'Ukraine est absolument
considérable l'actualité du jour nous le
rappelle une génération d'hommes est
engagée au combat sur son sol dans le
conflit le plus violent déjà vu l'Europe
depuis la fin de la Seconde Guerre
mondiale alors bien sûr les élus
américains demeurent sensibles à cette
réalité mais contrairement à sa dernière
visite qui consistait essentiellement à
demander de l'aide militaire et
financière à l'Allier américain cette
fois le président ukrainien est aussi là
pour rendre des comptes et parler de
l'avancée des opérations sur le terrain
les investissements américains dans la
guerre en Ukraine ont été absolument
colossaux depuis février 2022 depuis le
début du conflit le Congrès se trouve
aujourd'hui devant l'obligation de
rendre des comptes lui aussi au peuple
américain sur l'usage qui a été faite
c'est fond nous avons stoppé l'avancée
de l'armée russe jusqu'à la faire
reculer sur ses positions à d'îles
président ukrainien nous avons réalisé
l'impossible en tenant en échec l'une
des plus puissantes armées du monde
personne ne peut en effet remettre en
cause l'immensité du sacrifice ukrainien
mais si volodimeki ne veut pas subir la
lassitude du contribuable américain
cette fois ou pire encore de sa classe
politique le président ukrainien est
obligé d'être plus précis les chats
Abrahams promis par Washington joueront
bientôt un rôle clé dans la
contre-offensive en cours de même que
les chasseurs F16 dont il n'était pas
question il y a encore un an mais pour
lesquels désormais l'Amérique forme des
pilotes Ukrainiens dans des lieux encore
tenus secrets pour continuer à soutenir
l'Ukraine l'Amérique a besoin de
victoire et volodimeers etinski le sait
depuis son dernier passage à Washington
la chambre de représentants est tombée
aux mains des républicains il va donc
falloir convaincre Kevin McCarthy que
cette guerre peut être gagnée pour qu'à
son tour le chef de fil des républicains
à la chambre basse puisse atténuer les
doutes exprimées par l'aile droite de
son parti au moment où l'inflation
repart ici aux États-Unis et la question
des dépenses publiques va devenir
centrale surtout à mesure que les
parties vont s'installer dans la
campagne présidentielle pour 2024 ça
aussi zelins ki le sait une part de
l'avenir de son pays se joue ici à
Washington au cœur des intrigues
politiques entre démocrates et
républicains merci beaucoup Mathieu